today's video is sponsored by surf shark
what nora went through or more
accurately what she became in the last
two years was a man yeah a little bit
shorter on the top
no nora didn't get a sex change
operation she did it the old-fashioned
way with acting and a disguise and then
there's the theatrical component ah so
just easy tarzan out on your chest a
little ah
juilliard voice teacher kate moray
coached nora for months on a program of
movement breathing and speaking i want
you to be the best man you can be all to
incorporate some of the subtle and not
so subtle characteristics of being a guy
notice what men do if they need to
suddenly grab a taxi hey they just do
that whereas women will ask for a taxi
instead of demand one
when all the pieces are together hair
makeup voice posture style the
transformation is complete
[Applause]
and maura vincent becomes ned vincent
[Music]
so it never gets cold were you back in
australia throughout the project ned
dabbled in the art of picking up a woman
where'd your friend go we went with him
to this bar wearing hidden cameras it's
my friend jc i'm dead nora was reminded
that in this arena it's women who have
all the power we sit there and we just
with one
word no we'll crush someone and the
thing is we don't have to do the part
where you cross the room and you go up
to a stranger and say the first words
and those first words are so hard to say
without sounding like a cheese ball or
sounding like a jerk or whatever else
yeah what do you guys do keep in mind
she's a lesbian
and even though she's probably had to do
approaching approaching as a lesbian is
nothing like having to approach women as
a man no because regardless now right
the woman's got i mean the woman's guard
it down right it's not the same thing
right so she had to do it as a man and
she hasn't been a man most her life so
she's not even comfortable in that and
look at nora says the brush off barbara
jones gave ned was typical she was just
sort of emblazoned with hostility you
know just looked at you and you saw
everything cross her face which was oh
god help me not again i'm trying to have
a drink with a friend and i've got to
deal with you barbara was trying to
dispose of ned before her friend
returned from the bathroom
[Music]
but ned returned and told barbara the
truth about her gender saying you gave
us all the lines like trying to get rid
of us i see and as a woman i have such
sympathy i'm like oh i hate being this
guy that you're trying to get rid of
talking to a woman barbara seemed more
open and friendly and in the end
actually apologized for how she had
treated men i'm sorry for being [ __ ]
please oh you're not one of them all
right you good yeah i'm sorry for being
with you you guys want to talk about
rejection man
man i'm gonna tell you guys one of the
craziest rejection stories i ever had
i'm talking about such a big out to this
day it scarred me so my young years i
was doing my thing went to the gym the
girl behind the teller um
i was like what what you laughing cuz
you told me about this [ __ ] no she's
lying
okay ah so i asked for her number right
and she gives it to me i'm like cool
friday this is giving you mine it's
tuesday when i get her number i'm like
friday only go out after you're doing
your shift she said quick oh okay guys
if i go in go do my workout leave
feeling myself you know what i mean
because i got her number she was kind of
cute you know what i'm saying
so we texting during the week and on
thursday she stops responding but i'm
like we already agreed to friday so it's
all good i'm saying young boy gonna show
up to the gym all right
i show them to the gym yo stop laughing
yo stop laughing [ __ ]
why are you laughing at my pain
yo yo yo get up here and be respectful
get up here and be respectful
no it's not because you're laughing in
the back no no no no no you're going to
go back what do you want to go nah bro
so you're gonna be on screen being
respectful okay you're gonna be
respectful yeah please man your voice
cracking up yeah it's pain
okay go ahead that's what happens so
friday comes right and i'm sure
you gonna sit here
okay
and you go listen i'm sorry okay so what
happened all right friday happens so i
show up there friday night for closing
shift right and i'm waiting for her to
come off her shift i wait outside very
respectful to want to show up at her
workplace you know we cool and i text
i'm like yo i'm outside we're good to go
30 minutes close i see the gym close the
door so i know she's closing up i'm
waiting i'm chilling
just keep on going this is the most
painful part can you stop
okay
yeah elizabeth if you're watching turn
this off
so
i see the doors open and out she comes
with another man
right this guy's like six six
big old white dude right
and i see a cab pull up
i'm staring i'm maybe like 50 feet away
i'm like standing at the edge just
outside of the light you know because it
was night time you know they had a
little lamppost and i was standing in
the darkness
staring at these two living their best
life and they come out
and they start getting into the cab and
just as i think they're about to see me
i look to my right and i see some bushes
and i jump inside the bushes
[Laughter]
like it's a metal gear you ever seen
metal gear silence
where they jump where you just press the
box and he's just inside
so i'm inside these bushes
bruh i've never been in bushes in my
life despite being african believe what
you will i've never been no bushes in my
life
i'm hiding in these bushes
waiting to hear this cat pull up
and it's like a little bit of a
roundabout right
the calf starts going and then it
circles around it comes right in front
of the bushes
i hear the
i hear the window get pulled down
and then i hear a voice gay
hey we know you're in there
[Music]
guys if you guys are enjoying today's
video be sure to like and comment
like it comment it helps out that
algorithm today's video is sponsored by
surf shark vpn so vpn is basically an
application or web extension that you
could use on your web browser or on your
internet to mask your ip address
basically hiding your location from
whatever website you're interacting with
now you might think
why would i want to hide where i'm at it
doesn't matter well unfortunately there
are places that block you based off of
your ip address and so if you're trying
to view online content on let's download
certain things based off where you live
those things could be restricted now i
like watching tv shows feel me sometimes
they're foreign feel me and when that
happens
basically i use a vpn to be able to
bypass that so i can watch what i want
to watch because i feel like the
internet's at its best when everything's
accessible if you use promo code abba
and preach you get 83 off plus three
months free
so take advantage of the deal watch what
you want to watch and don't be
restricted by anyone's barriers you
deserve to go wherever you'd like to go
oh
um
so i hear them close up the window of
the taxicab
and pull out
and they just drive
and i can see the car leaving the
parking lot
and i just sat in the bushes for like
another two minutes
i did
looking back at your life
i've deleted her number and i never went
back to that gym
yeah man that's real
i'm crying because of your pain bro
and i wish i had a good ending for you
guys while i'm saying like
you know i mean there's no good ending
she got she got chlamydia after i wish i
had some i got nothing there's no
justice
yeah that's life
yes life
but uh anyways
yeah
i'm good
so
these are some of the experiences and
i've got a couple other ones like that
some brutal brutal rejections please
tell us another one no no that's that
was enough self-esteem blow for me for
one day
but i just want you ladies to understand
what some of that rejection feels like
do you really enjoy that
it's a [ __ ] up story man it's not you
it's just
you know what it is what is it
not only i'm petty i'm a fan of
penniness that was petty yeah that was
me and cause when he rolled down the
window and said yo we know you're in
there back basically i'm about to [ __ ]
your girl
oh
not mr steele girl mr [ __ ] your girl oh
bro this is just
yeah man guys
oh
it is
yeah
after that i changed my um
my username online to supreme gentlemen
why would you die but you were at the
gym
bro
shout out to the guinea force but uh but
yeah man that's some real [ __ ] and
listen rejection is part of the game
like i said i would we used to do this
thing where we would go out and like you
would do all this corny stuff with
sharpies and talking to a bunch of
strange women so you get used to the
rejection but that one stung i didn't
even go on french on i was early in my
time getting used to talking to women so
that's definitely the kind of l that
will uh mess you up hey listen i was
super dusty back then
that was a big l
[ __ ] you think i'm dusty too hey
i was really dusty back then so you can
imagine how often these kinds of things
happen and also the funny thing is my
best friend the guy who i used to go out
with we were in the military together
he's extremely handsome
so if you want any reminder of how
unfair life is i used to go out with
this [ __ ] and he would pull all the
time and he wasn't that good shout out
to you you know what i'm saying but you
know what i'm saying he he looked good
i've seen him he's well put together
yeah yeah
it is what it is right so like i was
like team
but that's just the way the game works
so as a man you just kind of have to
accept that burden or
you could just sit home watch anime all
day and play video games which you did
both damn right
damn right you did both damn right you
damn right
bam
crazy times but again this is one of
those things that women will never
understand or have to the same way guys
are not going to understand the fear
that women feel sometimes when they're
walking home whatever
and that fear is real right they're
never going to understand so she gets in
there she's like damn what guys have to
go through is difficult okay and she
said it too she said and can crush your
soul with just a few words and you know
it comes back to that whole thing where
it's like
a lady asked me why do guys do that
whole cat calling thing with like hey
baby huh and i heard someone else say
this but they say it's just a preemptive
strike because guys already know that
these women are probably going to reject
them anyways so they start to act
outside of themselves to blunt
the damage or that rejection because
these guys want intimacy they want
closeness with women but they know that
if they are themselves or they believe
that women are going to crush them so
they create this alternate persona where
they're like really gross and black hey
baby
huh so when the girl says no he can just
be like oh whatever huh but deep down
inside is just self-preservation at the
end of the day i still approached yes
she gave me the rejection that she gave
me but at least i gave her a reason to
reject me yeah because if i go just
there be like uh hey i just noticed no
ill
that hurts but if i like yo baby yeah
you look good ill like yeah your you
matches that yes so it feels
it feels less bad here's the difference
between men and women women can feel
rejection
right they can feel rejected by a
partner they can understand that yeah
the problem lies in when you guys get
rejected even if you guys don't go out
of your way to ever approach people you
can still get offers people will still
approach you and try with you as a man
if you are mediocre or below if you
don't put yourself out there
nobody will ever proposition you
ever
so
when you deal with that rejection you
know the choice is either
die alone or go and put yourself out
there and make an effort
so that's the difference between the
existence and you know especially when
you're less attractive my my younger
dicks man were rough
you know when your other homes like when
girls approach but they just want to
[ __ ] your homie if you don't know what
that's like to be the invisible one when
you go out and a lot of ugly girls
understand this as well but guess what
even the ugly girls will have dudes
approach them because just dudes you
don't want i'm saying the ugly dudes get
nothing and this is also buried
throughout like online dating statistics
like make up makeup profile as an
average to ugly woman
you'll get a lot of matches still
maybe not matches you want but if you
swipe on everyone i promise you even if
you're ugly
you still don't end up with matches uh
dude if he's ugly got bad pictures he
could swipe as long as he wants cause a
girl a girl has to be presentable he
will match because he will match but you
know who it's gonna be bots a girl has
to be presentable
a guy
if he's presentable
he still has to go out there
are you still talking about these
freshmen
bro
i can't tell you how many times the
first few times i was on online dating a
match with a beautiful chick and i was
like oh [ __ ] yeah and she's like so go
check out my tiny chat because i'm
bro by that time by the fifth time i
seen that [ __ ] i already knew so every
time i would swipe right on an
attractive woman i'd be like is this a
bot at least sometimes the girl would be
real i'm like oh my god uh excuse me
she's like unmatched
you played yourself twice
if you guys know what i'm talking about
you guys ever thought a woman was a bot
and she turned out to be a real human
being that one hurts oh yeah buddies
people
i had flashbacks but people's lighting
in my dm and then i'm rude i had
flashbacks you understand when you dusty
and you ain't never had a hot girl
respond you match with even like a seven
and you be like
this about are you a bot is she a real
person and you already [ __ ] it up like
ew about what the [ __ ] you mean i'm a
real person and she just but that's what
i was saying what i was saying was girls
have to be presentable
but guys even when they're presentable
they still have to go out there
and get rejected yeah that's the
difference yeah
does that kind of living in the skin of
a man
in the bar scene in the dating scene
give you a different kind of respect for
men
it gives me a certain definite sympathy
and i don't mean that there's any
disrespect but
it just makes me understand what's going
on
nora as ned also went on about 30 dates
with women mostly arranging them on the
internet did you have any fun
rarely rarely it was just an idea yeah
she says the pressure of ned having to
prove himself was grueling nora was
surprised that many women had no
interest in the soft vulnerable man my
prejudice was that
the ideal man is a woman in a man's body
and i learned no that's really not there
are a lot of women out there who really
want a manly man
ultimately ned told most of his dates
that he was nora many of the women
reacted angrily
that's just a trap it's not and it's
interesting hearing her say this as a
lesbian too
why
she's already used to going on dates
with women yeah but it's not the same
thing but that's my point yeah right
because you'll hear that like oh you
think girls can't have game what about
lesbians it's not the same it's not it's
not the same right and so there's just
an interesting thing where
even she's used to approaching women
yeah but the moment she becomes a man
she understands the difference because
of the difference absolutely yeah
not dealing with the same [ __ ]
the garden is up so oh man but anyways
let us know what you guys think do you
guys feel there's a imbalance there
what's some of your worst rejection
stories leave it in the comments we
might read them out in the video one day
anyone here this is gonna be this is
gonna be real cause there's real [ __ ]
out there oh man there's some real [ __ ]
out there yeah i'm down for that
hit us with your best
story all right that's it deuces
yo
sorry about that it's just the way you
said the story okay